[Music]  let me ask you something Dom what's the  best thing in your life family no it's  not Vin Diesel and Charlize Theron share  some sexy scenes in the fate of the  Furious like according to Charlize the  sexual tension wasn't well there in real  life there's a hit quote here his  character this is about the kiss yeah  his characters just she said this on the  show she is just frozen like a dead fish  and once yep  what come on guys  ah no that looks like a Connie Corso  that's saying don't do this in front of  Letty that's what that is I know  yes been hilariously freaked out on The  Ellen DeGeneres Show but we think he  will be okay because the film is nearing  the 1 billion dollar mark after less  than a month in theatres but such a  wonderful sense of accomplishment  validation I'm just so happy  you  you